sur une rue tranquille d'une banlieue de
montréal une maison semblable aux autres
en apparence seulement car cette adresse
se retrouve au centre d'une constatation
internationale elle est associée à 18
compagnies la grande majorité
enregistrée aux îles vierges
britanniques et impliquent des comptes
de banque à monaco et gibraltar may
gisement d'or en russie des
investisseurs floués des fausses
promesses des trahisons un marché à haut
risque
des allégations de crime organisé et un
québécois dont le nom apparaît à de
nombreuses reprises dans la fameuse
banque de données offshore
[Musique]
l'homme qui vit à cette adresse
s'appelle normand theroux qui est ce
québécois aux multiples compagnies et
s'il à l'atteinte de ce vaste réseau
d'envergure internationale normand
theroux a accepté de nous rencontrer
mais il a refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue officielle
nous avons jugé bon d'utiliser la caméra
cachée
cet ancien avocat a été l'unique
directeur de toutes ses compagnies de
2006 à 2008
pourtant il semble entendre certaines
c'est non pour la première fois il n'est
pas très au courant non plus d'une
plainte à la fifa en 2011
cette agence américaine de surveillance
des courtiers a pour but de protéger les
investisseurs pourtant dans ce document
on retrouve son nom et 3 ses nombreuses
compagnies frères ford stratton et un
peu quick enregistrée aux îles vierges
britanniques
les compagnies selon la finra aurait été
créé uniquement pour liquider le plus
rapidement possible des millions
d'actions d'une compagnie appelée aux
russes une compagnie qui dit détenir des
droits sur un important gisement d'or en
russie cette compagnie theroux s'en
souvient
et
la compagnie hors us enregistrée dans
l'état du delaware a tiré entre autres
plusieurs investisseurs américains comme
luis enrique que nous avons rencontrés à
brooklyn
vous savez je n'en revenais pas la
possibilité d'avoir un retour sur
investissement de 20 à 30 fois plus
d'argent que ce que j'avais payé
aux russes étaient inscrits sur les pink
sheet une bourse ou les actions se
transigent enceinte un marché très
spéculatif est propice à la fraude
un gisement d'or en russie une compagnie
enregistrée aux états unis un bureau à
montréal
et parmi les dirigeants d'horus vieil
ami de normand theroux gerald park inn
il était charmant et convaincant savait
parler aux gens pour leur dire ce qu'ils
devraient faire avec leur argent ou
telle monnaie giral parking convainc
l'américain d'investir il y a beaucoup
d'effervescence autour du titre d'horus
sur les sites l'investisseur les
échanges sont nombreux les communiqués
de presse certains écrits par park inn
annonce de bonnes nouvelles
une vidéo tournée sur les lieux en
russie parle d'une méthode
révolutionnaire pour extraire l'or pour
couronner le tout un rapport géologique
d'une firme russe estimerait la valeur
du gisement à plus de 2 milliards de
dollars 3 2 milliards et demi d'actifs
vous plaisantez c'est un investissement
incroyable vachement
globalement pour eaux russes est à son
comble quand un journaliste australien
en russie publie une information qui a
l'effet d'une bombe
les actifs russes étaient inaccessibles
ou inexistants existantes
nous avons joué john earner sous skype
nous vérifions chacune des allégations
d'actifs
la licence ne pouvions pas trouvé la
preuve qu'ils occupaient le bureau
qu'ils disent est occupé par des offres
nous avons joué la firme russe et le
géologue qui a évalué le potentiel
minier du gisement
ils nous ont dit n'avoir jamais fait
d'estimation et que la signature du
géologue alexander romantchouk a été
falsifiée you believe et trois oscars et
vous croyez que c'était une fronde
je suis sûr que les investisseurs
pourraient penser à une expression plus
grossières arnaque serait un bon début
stade
monsieur n roll comme d'autres
investisseurs venaient de se faire
prendre dans ce qui avait toutes les
apparences d'un cas classique de pompey
nomme un type de manipulation boursière
michèle picard est un analyste du crime
financier
il en a vu passer des pommes ndom on va
mousser un titre en faisant des annonces
télévisées journaux instruite pour
augmenter la valeur du titre de façon
artificielle pour arriver un maximum ou
les investisseurs de départ ou vend le
côté d'amp vendre leurs actions ont dopé
leurs actions à un prix maximum et au
lendemain de la vente
l'action tombe à zéro parce que la
réelle valeur d'accompagner ses héros
louis sinon on perd 50 mille dollars ont
tous les investisseurs auraient perdu
plusieurs millions mais qui se cache
derrière cette mésaventure boursière
normand theroux et son univers de
compagnie gerald parking qui a été
président d'horus des investisseurs à
qui nous avons parlé sont unanimes c'est
géré par ken le nom de normand theroux
ne leur dit rien nous avons rencontré
giral parking à quelques reprises dans
les couloirs du palais de justice de
montréal
il comparaissait pour un autre dossier
de manipulation boursière par kenny
avoir sollicité des investisseurs
américains jamais par les investisseurs
américains des investisseurs qui ont
acheté des actions de russes jamais
parlé à aucun investisseur
il affirme qu russe était une compagnie
légitime ce qui complique tous je
demande à voir connaissent et qui
forment la jeune homme absolument que
des investisseurs qui restent floues et
effets surprenants parking dit ne pas
connaître son ancien ami normand theroux
vous connaissez mon soutien
je ne sais pas mais c'est et ou pas du
tout vous avez jamais rencontré monsieur
théo notre enquête démontre qu'ils se
connaissent depuis plus de 30 ans ils
ont même partagé un bureau d'avocats
[Musique]
dans cette histoire de qui dit vrai une
chose est sûre les investisseurs ont
perdu beaucoup d'argent et selon la
finra
une partie de l'argent soit 2,2 millions
de dollars obtenus de la vente des
actions de russes ont transité par les
trois compagnies theroux avant d'être
transférés dans des comptes de banque à
monaco et gibraltar normand theroux
avoue être allé à monaco pour ouvrir des
comptes de banque mais à la demande de
gerald parking ils ignoraient qu'il y
avait un compte à son nom à gibraltar
dans des compagnies à votre nom que vous
n'avez jamais eu rien vu
or
pour nous démontrer sa bonne foi et nous
donne accès à un de ses anciens comptes
courriel un conte auquel il dit ne plus
avoir accès au monde mis notre
recherchiste à revient à le réactiver en
quelques minutes
plus de 400 courriel mais mme théroux
est étonné par l'ampleur des messages il
nous dit que park inn a créé ce compte
pour communiquer avec les banquiers et
les courtiers pour moi par la suite
communiqué
théroux va plus loin et affirme que park
inn s'est servi de son nom de son titre
d'avocat et qu'il aurait même imité sa
signature
nous avons à nouveau confronté gerald
park inn au palais de justice de
montréal
le nom de normand theroux lui dit
soudainement quelque chose et toujours
selon park inn theroux travailler pour
un groupe d'hommes d'affaires russes qui
avaient besoin d'un avocat pour ouvrir
des compagnies dans les paradis fiscaux
et mettre leur argent à l'abri de
l'impôt par qu'il ne pouvait pas jouer
ce rôle parce qu'ils n'étaient plus
avocat derrière ces deux québécois qui
se renvoient la balle des russes
semblent donc tirer les ficelles est
certain selon nos sources serait relié
au crime organisé
[Musique]
dans toute cette histoire d'ouvertures
de comptes à l'étranger d'achat et de
vente de milliers d'actions il a fallu
des intermédiaires pour départager le
vrai du faux
nous avons retracé l'un d'entre eux qui
a préféré taire son identité
combien de fois vous avez vu monsieur
guy roux quelques reprises l'homme parce
qu'ils ouvrent des compagnies c'était
plus dans les signatures de documents
officiels
c'est vraiment sa signature un parce
qu'il nous a dit que on avait imité sa
signature par froid sur des documents
sur des ouvertures de comptes
non pas du tout météo insiste je mets le
poteau 3 une autre compagnie de terreau
parkin nous a avoué avoir signé à
quelques reprises le nom de normes anti
roux mais toujours avec son consentement
pourtant theroux ne semble pas au
courant d'une commande pour une étampe
payé par gerald parking une étampe qui
aurait servi croit theroux a authentifié
de nombreux documents à sa place théroux
avait besoin d'argent il vendait en
quelque sorte son nom nous avons parlé à
un autre témoin de cette époque qui a
aussi préféré conserver l'anonymat
il confirme que theroux voulait mettre
fin à cette association
à un moment donné j'ai appris que leur
relation était terminée entre les deux
de façon qui ne semble pas vraiment
faire plaisir à monsieur theroux dans le
sens que c'est lui qui semble être celle
à quitter leur relation cet homme a vu
de l'intérieur ce qui se passait avec
toutes ces compagnies offshore
il a connu les deux québécois mais aussi
un certain bien czeslaw makarov leur
partenaire russe à montréal makarov
représentaient les propriétaires de la
compagnie aux russes je crois que
monsieur père qui travaillait pour les
russes
il y avait un lien d'autorité et je
crois que l'autorité c'était des russes
mais qui sont ces russes une vidéo
promotionnelle tournée en 2007 nous
permet d'en identifier quelques uns
fedor d'organes
la tête dirigeante d'horus et ses
associés
valentine shégués neige et sergei
salnikoff ce sont eux les vrais
propriétaires de cette constellation de
compagnies enregistrées au nom de
normand theroux mais heureusement ils
viennent de subir et donne des
instructions à l'europe une voiture
c'est par elle que tu dois ma dîme ce
tir ou de quelconques de telle personne
est même le seul avec qui j'avais dit
qu'en sait on
tout à fait j'avais eu le choix leur
argent c'est mon nom qui était dans mes
cours d'année film nader ce qu'il
fallait ce f4 les gens veulent avoir des
nouvelles
il m'appelait mais moi quand j'étais au
coin devient je dépends de personne je
vous dirai que j'y vis plus monsieur
point que dit monsieur makarov
monsieur terre-rouge niveau au début
pour signer les documents mais après ça
c'était je voyais plus monsieur theron
d'après notre témoin c'était jura le
park inn et bien tu slave makarov qui
vendait les actions il était pressé de
le faire ce qui était important pour eux
c'était d'avoir leur argent le plus
rapidement possible ils étaient prêts à
payer de grosses commissions à la limite
juste pour vous depuis avoir leur argent
makarov semblait prendre toutes les
décisions
c'est avec les urgences puis du solde de
vouloir avoir l'argent tout seul c'est
sûr qu'en guise sous roche
selon une source sûre laitue slave
makarov serait spécialiste de la
manipulation boursière et ferait partie
du groupe tachkent une branche de la
mafia russe en ouzbékistan est ce que
vous les crédits les rousses je suis
prudent j'ai plus d'un sacyr quoi je
suis très d'un je me dis ben ça de près
des enfants qu'un l'homme à l'origine de
ce partenariat entre les russes et les
québécois s'est armé nac safarov selon
nos sources safarov seraient aussi
impliqués dans la mafia ouzbek le
blanchiment d'argent et l'importation
d'héroïne makarov et park inn ont eu
d'autres liens d'affaires avec cet homme
au québec
[Musique]
certaines personnes dans l'entourage de
monsieur martin qui l'ont côtoyé on dit
que monsieur par keane avait beaucoup
plus part des russes qu'ils avaient peur
de la mmf ou des poursuites qu'il
fallait qu'ils livrent la marchandise
canton du parcq et non plus par des
russes que de la m s
bon
ça se passe pour ajouter à la complexité
de toute cette histoire
une enveloppe anonyme arrive à nos
bureaux c'est un investisseur qui écrit
avoir tout perdu dans l'histoire d'horus
je ne peux vous donner mon nom car ils
m'ont fait des menaces à moi et ma
famille que si je parlais je subirai
leur colère et j'ai peur parmi les
documents de l'envelope eux nous éclaire
sur la manière dont l'argent a pu
circuler et revenir au pays
c'est un transfert de 550 mille dollars
américains d'une banque de monaco à une
compagnie alpha capital finance en
juillet 2006
l'année suivante alpha capital près de
500 mille dollars à park inn pour
financer la maison où il habitait à
laval cette compagnie enregistrée aussi
oser le vierge britannique a été créé
comme un peu cuite ferait fort et
stratcom pour y déposer également le
fruit de la vente des actions d'horus
elle a impliqué les mêmes joueurs
parking makarov leurs associés en russie
salnikoff et normand theroux qui avoue
avoir signé le prêt pour la maison
les juridictions internationales parce
que ce sont des compagnies sont à gauche
et à droite sur la planète complique
énormément les enquêtes
aucune accusation n'a jamais été porté
dans l'histoire d'horus nous avons tenté
de joindre les représentants de la
compagnie en russie nous n'avons pu
retracer que service sannikov qui lui a
une autre version des faits d'antan on
essayait de pénétrer le marché boursier
américain avec cet actif mais nos
partenaires canadiens ont tout gâché
ils n'ont pas tiré de l'argent il y en a
perdu 50
viatcheslav makarov partage son temps
entre le québec la france et la russie
où il est vu ce macaron soirée où est ce
que ce sera possible de rencontrer ce
serait leur faut que je vous l'demande
extrait placées en lui après plusieurs
tentatives pour le joindre bien tu cela
makarov nous rappelle et nous donne
rendez vous il a une condition aucune
caméra
il est accompagné de parking makarov dit
à peine connaître normand theroux il
ajoute qu russe était une compagnie
sérieuse que c'était loin d'être un
pantin d'hommes quant aux allégations de
manipulation boursière et de mafia russe
il nie en bloc
normand theroux lui refuse désormais de
nous parler
il avait pourtant toujours été très
volubile nous nous sommes présentés chez
lui il ne veux plus répondre à nos
questions évoquées russe au départ tout
avait commencé avec son nom inscrit à de
nombreuses reprises dans une banque de
données offshore et une adresse sur une
rue tranquille une maison semblable aux
autres
en apparence seulement
[Musique]